countdown to class we're just 12 days
away now from the start of hybrid
learning for some pre-kindergarten to
third grade
clark county school district students
but as 8 news now reporter kristen
drummond shows us that is not the only
focus
some secondary school students may also
be back on campus next month
not for hybrid learning but possibly
participating in voluntary small groups
and hopefully we'll get it soon so we
can really start working out the
logistics
various principals submitting plans
based on their school needs earlier this
month some continue waiting for approval
from regional superintendents
including tam larnard who wants students
returning march 1st
the clock is ticking for the school year
the spring valley high school principal
says
his plan focuses on three areas students
struggling emotionally
seniors at risk of not graduating and
those in advance placement or the
international baccalaureate program
bring them in in groups to work with
their teachers
you know for the ib kids these exams are
the culminating assessment after two
years in these classes
across town at las vegas high school in
the east valley principal ron gerzon
keeps his plan fairly broad
at any given time we want only 10 of the
student body
to be on campus and that's about 270
kids
and it would require
at least 30 teachers both gerzon and
larnard requesting bus service
an ask originally not offered by the
district when trustees agreed to bring
small groups on campus
i believe the equity voices were heard
that we need if we're going to offer
this to
some students we really need to offer to
all students transportation staff will
review plans and
are expected to collaborate with schools
to best fulfill the request
according to the forum principles
submitted in the newsroom i'm kristen
drummond 8 news now
some parents say the lack of consistency
among schools is pretty frustrating
the district continues focusing on the
return of lower elementary school
students to class again on march first
and eight news now is counting down the
days leading to students being welcomed
back to campus
you can follow along with eight news now
as we bring you all of those back to
school updates brian